how's your in space welcome back to
another episode a wall for mangas
episode 3 part 2 it actually makes sense
this time only shed I asked you bros in
the last last episode who of them I
should pick it was pretty most of you
said the trip-trap and I kinda have to
agree with you I'll go to the trip-trap
so we'll go through tech settings I
think that's our best option
sounds good but what enough kid's name
and hope you find something in the
records let me know what he comes up
with I'll be in touch
I hope you'll do the same we'll catch
him snow hang on Jack hello to you are
we gonna talk to him as snow no that
doesn't done diddly diddly diddly is he
gonna get pissed I wouldn't keep our
side of the deal er nah nah this is
awkward so what are you today what's
that
oh well that's weird okay you're really
weird geez I can't believe you did that
tell me more okay now bored why is it
not loading their game please load oh oh
there we go all right you can tell me
after the video sorry about that the
trip chop bar oh wait okay
I'll show you in a second she's asleep
you [ __ ] idiot
you didn't even give me a chance what
the [ __ ] is left to explain just you
know what happened
we're closed I need to talk to Holly so
yeah actually open hi
Hey look woody it's the sheriff
Wow
come on in buddy friend what he's a
traveler a weary traveler search of some
hospitality right right I mean you must
not be feeling too good after that [ __ ]
show yeah I felt pretty good only be
here two minutes just need to check
through Lily's things mm-hmm
whatever what do they do exactly like
what's their job huh
just being I don't want to drink anybody
else want a drink
friend Swinehart said you shouldn't mix
think I give a [ __ ] what that [ __ ]
guy says or what you say hey he got shot
too grunt really shouldn't drink right
now you should quit while you're ahead
with that stuff I might need your help
Ali's are sleeping back but you won't be
able to wake her really why the doc gave
them both bar methanol ambrosia and for
the pain but the deal is if you're is
this going to sleep like I am right now
it gives you a very very very nice
and he said that he shouldn't mix it
with alcohol hi you can't do that don't
do that buzz yes she did
now certainly did let me tell you
something oh [ __ ] I haven't felt this
good in a long time fat boy have you
seen her sister's things what wasn't
burned at the funeral I saw her come in
with something but I didn't see where
she put it
nope haven't seen it why don't we just
ask woody that funeral back there that
was a shitty [ __ ] send-off for a
pretty okay lady
no you weren't [ __ ] there talking a
big B now okay how's the young
millionaire help things much Grenn don't
start nothin who's starting anything I'm
not right now I couldn't give a [ __ ]
what you think
no no well I can tell
whatever it's alright I'm too out of it
to get into haha I want to clear the air
we're all in this dung heap of a [ __ ]
[ __ ] town together we're all gonna have
a toast all of us fellas I'm here for
one thing to look through Lily's
belongings and get out of here yeah yeah
I know I know and I want to help you
okay
and I will but first indulge me
it'll take two seconds the [ __ ] you're
so annoying good faith and after we'll
all hunt and peck for Lily [ __ ] or
whatever ran Bigby didn't come here to
get loaded with you I don't want to get
loaded with him it's just a quick slug
not gonna hurt anybody I'm running out
of time gran
Wiseman is the dog said you needed a rap
you [ __ ] gotta warn me about it huh
you're not my [ __ ] mother so just get
off my back I said I was sorry all right
I can't do anything about it it's gone
of course that's what I knew what more
do you want
what else can I [ __ ] say here cut
this [ __ ] out now I don't care what it's
about
oh I forgot you haven't heard the news
this walking large cake was paying
Holly's sister to let him [ __ ] her
behind all of our backs and Holly had to
find out going through all of her
sisters [ __ ] what fun that must have
been trick after trick of this fat-ass
and little I didn't plan for that all
right what the forest thing whatever it
was it wasn't a big deal
it wasn't I've never [ __ ] her when she
was snowing what I didn't know nothing
about that no but you knew Holly would
flip out and you knew for a damn good
[ __ ] reason he has a beautiful beer
don't be hating know what [ __ ] this I
don't need this [ __ ]
oh yeah that's it now you're teary-eyed
you were always such a lowlife I don't
know why I never realized it till now
what do you think about this [ __ ]
loser sheriff stop saying the [ __ ]
much she wants I don't give a [ __ ] wait
wait I've got some questions for you
what possible questions could you have
for this piece of [ __ ] everything's a
problem when I want to talk but when the
woodsman's about to leave
it's oh wait I have questions yeah what
do you want
he's bald I want to know how tell me
everything
when you saw Lily did she ever mention
anything about a witch
we didn't talk about work all right
well that went [ __ ] great Jesus we're
not getting any way Grenn I don't know
where Lily [ __ ] is check Holly's room I
don't know but I wouldn't wake her if I
were you
it's probably gonna sit on my Walker not
die Wales I'm to think that's the rule
maybe ogres - thanks for the actually
Big B if you'll excuse me it seems that
I'm gonna pass out yeah all right
Sheriff what [ __ ] day he won't
remember this ha ha it's kind of funny
actually uh Jesus Christ don't wake the
troll what is this a fad that's ironic
she's probably sleeping on the [ __ ] yeah
it's right there isn't it
all right let's not touch her creative
alcohol what have we got here
absolutely nothing it looks like we have
to tie - it ain't nothing con let's
touch a cot whatever that is I don't
want to touch her where's the cot
what's a cot this is a cot are you a cot
mr. cot oh that's the coach yes you
could easily just
I could easily you know a document sorry
come on Stu it all right let's poker
don't touch her
this is very inappropriate don't do this
don't do I can't believe you two that
holy [ __ ]
god damn it yes so many freckles oh well
that was easy
should have had some whipped cream ready
for this get it cuz she's fine she's a
fine lady that's what I'm saying
right prefer them like that this is me
that you woody
ah I'm just here for Lily's things
hallelujah go back to sleep
Big B bars closed
you forgot to take off your makeup who's
me but I'm not in the mood for
entertaining but what the [ __ ] I know
you're not gonna leave you do what you
want you always do what you want yeah
how's easy ha ha alright I have a a
bottle of wine and a picture
let's check the picture you can see him
in the background there that fat [ __ ]
nothing what we being fat I didn't just
say it rides and I don't like him do you
even give a [ __ ] about us the strays the
ones that aren't in that fancy high-rise
those of us that kind of work for a
living
my yes because I live in the woodlands
doesn't mean I'm not one of your
strengths and that crane or coal I
didn't exactly grow up wearing clothes
I know you didn't alright so now we can
take one of these that we found before
and we can oh it's another path oh allah
passes yeah my oh we have this already
[ __ ]
jeah strikes again come here
I got it Jeff there's nothing here to
investigate I can't be any use to you
I need to look through your sisters
things to look for clues um if you want
to put it that way well that's kind of
what it is right I don't know why you
both wanted to go hear her now cuz like
then I'd really select the right one
what I thought we were going to the the
two little [ __ ] we already checked all
this let me there's no oh we got the
address of the [ __ ] chiana's sheriff
why are you going after him what guy
that killed Lily I believe in justice
with a long time ago but you still got
one why cuz it looks like you have
bananas on your forehead job for a
reason
oh what's this the only thing Jesus
Christ this is for faith I have the
history with the killer the business
office would let you do I'm doing this
for faith ah least you're honest
you just remember whatever [ __ ]
excuse you tell yourself um countin on
you well I think you've been an Elaine
any more fuck-ups okay all right do we
have the name Jesus were so full of suck
right now I don't know what to do about
dad getting your glamour on this day and
one of these has to be the witch yes Oh
leave uh-huh gotcha gotcha
I knew that hello this is no I calling
I'm looking for Big B well I guess we
can is anyone there
yeah okay so Benjamin
I got it's no her address was here with
Lily's things it's on White Plains
Avenue 1284 it's an apartment complex
great let's get going
cranes meeting her in a few minutes
listen we have to hurry
I click let go all right I'll see you
there III panic and that I don't know
what to click ok huh
oh we got a little bug in here thanks
for me girl
Vance Vance that's Betty
Edgar's just looking at me like what the
[ __ ] are you doing you little bit
you're too black to be seen like I do
thank me there we are
sorry mother I'll never do that again I
promise Pathak is a game pros - that's
great come on come on don't I just got
here yeah me too
it's number 23 I haven't seen it yet
we're late yeah I know this is it all
right how do you want to do this
um
since we're late wait wait wait wait
what are you doing better look like
don't just kick it in we don't know
what's on the other side let's just save
the last resort for the last fine okay
what would you have me do instead yeah
no knock I mean we have no idea what's
behind you're dragging out the time lady
ain't got time for these are the doors
open hello
oh Jesus ice creepy hi
you woke me up
uh sorry about that there's something
wrong I don't think I've ever seen you
before
well pardon the intrusion you see the
witch isn't aware this was a munchkins
house no Dorothy it isn't no sharp kid
and who are you
Rachel who are you I've added Sam so we
are not strangers well I'm the sheriff
and this is my partner boss hostage
hello his anti Greenleaf at home does
she live here you mean my mom she ever
once make the nightstand levitate turn
frogs into cats
that kind of things she a witch dear no
I would never call my mommy bad she
treats me all right
I don't think you get it something you
want I don't think I can really help you
it's better snow Desa talking with this
guy or something here never any idea
what to say to these people you mean
children I selling sell mean yeah if my
friend here takes a look around I
promise we'll be quick so you can hurry
back to bed
well she didn't get to answer all night
nobody's been here it's a crap okay boss
I'm gonna trust your friend not to break
anything don't get me in trouble look
for anything unusual
it's a crime like crane you could still
be here it's totally a crime
I can smell it all right okay
so let's find a witch it's pretty rare
to see a burner like this dowdy
that's how we like it no I don't trust
that all right what what about this
portrait thing huh what about that
mm-hmm do you ever change your dress
how about that huh suspicious let me
guess big band or clash accord honky
tonk no accounting for taste that's true
let's in this closet huh I found you now
I knew it
you have a skeleton in here ah the
butcher the butcher what's that a
package having to do with someone called
the butcher
it's empty
huh interesting I wonder not here
there's no one here but me okay I heard
you that sweetheart
but Papa Perth's has to take a little
look around you see can't go trusting
anybody now in these days no no no over
all night he's just going to check
George barley take a moment
yeah it's fun second night sweetheart
let's kind of check over here oh oh you
don't want me to check here do you
alright have a nothing that looks like
crane was here either
nothing see I don't like this I'd uh
what about this huh
your mama hunter no she never that was
found in the woods around Dix Mountain
I think hey why this spider over there
yesterday Oh
which god she's a witch no one likes
spiders what is this no one uses that
des Carver trinkets it's from the old
world trinkets I'm like Glamour's
didn't see that nothing keep getting
whiffs of that aftershave of his I do
too
can I go to bed now please no I said no
mmm is that a glamour tube mommy really
doesn't let anyone play with that trust
me
try is he oh please please please just
put that back exactly where you found it
no one is allowed to play what it's all
right honey Vicky's not going to break
you don't understand that you will freak
out if she discovers I let people in
here let them touch her stuff okay how I
hate ex all the time to see if things
move I don't want to get in trouble I'm
not gonna break it I just want to open
it down please you gotta believe me
the guy isn't here I promise gonna be
okay Rachel hey ya guy hey I don't wanna
I don't want to get in trouble
like I hate when you do it that fast
she was so Cowie but now she's not so
Sugoi what you think we have time to
waste on this [ __ ] I think this is some
kind of game no I don't but
congratulations on winning it if that
matters to you know your entree I'm like
it start it's like and from the
beginning none of this [ __ ] Sisyphus
is gonna prevent me from prying what I
need from your gullet
now tell me where crane naina
fortune-teller wolf
I have no heavenly idea where he went to
you have to know something unless you
want a recipe for owls do just why in
the name of everything holy are you
protecting this reason lys come back I
mean what on earth could he have done to
deserve this kind of loyalty crane could
be hollow bones tomorrow and you
wouldn't see me cry o'clock I thought it
said drug crime ooh but that doesn't
mean I can tell you anything you have
friends don't you
well I don't want cranes friends for
enemies you want to get shipped off to
the farm huh I'll have you kept in the
horse's stables
[ __ ] tell me where he is or we can
skip the sentencing and go straight to
judgment hallelujah
there are worse things in life than
darkness Sheriff worse things than you
oh yeah problems in your farm
there's powers at work here beyond your
pathetic authority whatever it is green
leaf whatever it is that's keeping you
from saying something you have to those
two are not gonna work is it I don't
give a [ __ ] about your problems just
talk now you have no idea what's going
on do you
oh god damn it a haven there like that
okay you know what I think I think we've
been more than patient with me not
really that which has been selling
illegal Glamour's that continue to
undermine everything we've built she's
harboring a fugitive that took advantage
of it which oh she's resisting every
attempt to make things right I frankly
don't give a crap if she's afraid for
her life we can at least make sure she
never hurts us again wow so we're
destroying the tree Oh dare you come in
here and threaten to take from me the
one thing that initially is ancient it's
part of the family and it's the only
thing paid for the [ __ ] apartment
and the fables who can't afford the
glamorous from you come to me for help
without them where do you think they
could don't give me that you're making
money off of other people's misery
two fatals are dead because of this crap
it's too dangerous leaving this stuff
with her you think I like being the old
woman in these stories the men are
heroes the ladies are [ __ ] and you're
a scientist like me to watch everyone
they love die we have very different
ways of handling our fate very different
means to handle it - and I don't use it
as an excuse to wreck people's Oh God
the train has to go we can truly loves
laughs don't do this we can't we can't I
don't do much see yes I can't end this I
mean what are we gonna do ruin this
woman's life it's a slap on the wrist
compared to what she's done I don't
understand why we have to kill the tree
this is an order
good cop bad cop that's what he would
look look I'll tell you what I see
you're working crane was here he was
here and he left he went to the pudding
and pie to try to use my ring on the
girls over there to get information
what is the ring do he thinks it's the
ring of despair you know that will
pierce the protection around the girls
speech he says pooling the truth out of
them will prove his innocence there you
go it won't though damn thing lost its
power decades ago what I'm sorry but we
still can't let you keep the tree it
wouldn't be right after what's happened
Big B
please Sheriff I don't know what you
recently told us no [ __ ] way we're
gonna have to burn it because you're
pissed off at crane for what he stole my
hair from my apartment baked me
so yeah I'm pissed but I still know
what's best for this town we're now
burning the trees no no we're not all
right let's go
Hey greenly
don't think this is over
I won't
sing-a-ling ding-ding sing-along dong
Chong I could do that all night long
while wearing a thong and playing the
trombone inside a ching chong i don't
know okay that's pretty good i hope you
bros enjoyed watching this episode i
don't know why my hair is all like it i
didn't I ran out of jail that's why but
you don't have to know that now you do
either way hope you will enjoy it like
if you did
thank you for watching especially I
think it's pretty interesting so far
I'll see you tomorrow with a new one
I'll be brush